Apple defined Swift functions as
self-contained to chunks of code
that perform a specific task.
There are three main types
of functions and swift.
Global functions,
Nested functions, and methods.
Nested functions
are slightly more advanced.
So we're going to focus on global
functions and methods for the moment.
Global functions are functions that
can be called from anywhere in an app.
Global function syntax is easy to
recognize because global functions
are called by a particular object.
They're just called sort
of floating in thin air.
One global function that you're
sure to be intimately familiar with
by now is print.
Global functions like print can be
called from anywhere within a class.
On the other hand,
when a function is defined in
an associated with a particular class,
we call that function a method.
The vast majority of Swift functions
that you write and call will be methods.
Here we have a method called sum of
strings which you may remember from your
exercises.
It's defined within
the arithmetic class.
And is also called by an instance
of the arithmetic class.